back in May the CDC said it was sending
Ebola guidelines to hospitals around the
nation to your knowledge were those
guidelines received and are nurses
receiving adequate training to deal with
ebola probably the guidelines were re
received but they're probably still in
somebody's desk or um being uh looked at
uh our studies clearly show that nurses
are not being given the Education and
Training they need in our Hospital
hospitals by our own survey so we're
extremely worried about the situation
Ma'am why do you not believe that they
are receiving proper
training uh well the CDC guidelines are
merely guidelines and when you have over
5,000 hospitals in the United States
that uh can choose which guidelines they
want to implement uh you have sort of a
free-for-all and that's what we're
concerned about we would like consistent
mandatory standards for all of the
hospitals to follow Professor gon
Jeffrey Levy is executive director of
trust for America's Health that's a
nonprofit focused on disease prevention
he told my colleagues here at Bloomberg
News quoting here while it's always
important to find dollars in the context
of an emergency it is just as important
to sustain our capacity to respond how
would you assess the country's capacity
to respond to the Ebola
virus well first of all I I don't think
there's going to be a major outbreak
here so I just want to calm some fears
about that on the other hand the cases
in Dallas uh with uh really apparent
breaches of protocol in almost every
respect not just the infection of the
but also the the quarantine of uh of for
uh contacts of Mr Duncan were were very
badly handled and I actually think that
we we need to do better with our Public
Health Capac capacity the cdc's funding
has been cut uh state and local Health
departments have been cut and I think
this just exposes our vulnerable
underbelly Miss Berger in the Impact
Zone in West Africa some Health Care
Professionals they've become sick and
some have refused to work because of
fear of Contracting the virus that is
where the International Community has to
step in are medical professionals here
in the United States answering that call
in great enough numbers to make a
difference
it really does not feel like um the
medical profession has been responding
inadequate numbers it's interesting to
note that Cuba has actually sent more
medical health professionals than the
United States and I think we really need
to step up to the plate because if we
don't stop the spread of Ebola in West
Africa it will spread globally and what
the nurses want to say is that we don't
want to spread fear we want to spread
Readiness and educ ation and we're
trying to make sure that we can hold our
employers accountable to providing that
Education and Training Professor gon
let's talk about that Readiness and
specifically about airport screenings
will screenings of passengers work or
are they a take charge approach designed
to lessen people's fears without
yielding any tangible
results well you know I think what we
what we've introduced is is reasonable
it's measured it's it's narrow only
affecting 150 people per day who
originate from one to three affected
countries but having said that it
probably won't work uh it'll make the
public feel slightly safer um but even
during SARS when we did Mass airport
screening in Canada and in Asia out of
hundreds of thousands of cases we
actually never found a real case of SARS
we probably won't find a real case of
Ebola either uh and there'll be lots of
false positives people with malaria and
it's also coming up the peak influenza
season so it's a reasonable thing to do
I'm not against it because it's not an
overreaction but I don't think we can
expect to keep it us safe what will keep
us safe is strengthening our Public
Health infrastructure here in America
and also getting the reservoir of in
ction which is currently out of control
in West Africa under control Miss Berger
when it comes to self-monitoring of
healthcare workers what are the standard
protocols to be followed especially in
emergency rooms which as you know are
the first point of Hospital entry for
ill patients well I think that's the
problem that we're dealing with right
now is it's pretty much hit or miss when
a patient presents in the hospital in
Sacramento we had a case where a patient
sat in the emergency room for up to 2
hours before they actually triaged the
patient and got them in the isolation
room so what we really want to make sure
is that people in the health care field
know what the drill is know how to do it
and can implement it at a moment's
notice because we even have computer
online booking of appointments so
patients can show up anywhere Professor
gon the CDC director Tom freden is
rejecting calls from some members of
Congress to ban travelers from Guinea
Liberia and Sierra Leon from entering
the United States what right does an
American citizen have to re-enter the
country even if they are showing signs
of
illness well first of all I do agree
with Tom freden I think it would be a
horrible idea to ban travel I think it
would make us much less safe because uh
Ebola would just run run out of control
in the region and that would put us at
risk um so I think it's a I think it's a
very very good idea to to reject that uh
that
claim I agree actually myself I think
that we can't wrap this country in Saran
Wrap and expect to not be exposed to
these diseases and I think preparation
and education is actually the key to uh
stopping the spread uh Miss Berger let
me get you the last word in here we have
about a minute left I wanted to ask ask
have you been in contact with any nurses
or Health Care Professionals who've
actually been on the ground in the
affected areas and if so what have they
told you no I have not been in contact
with them but we are um making sure
tomorrow that we have a call-in show
where uh nurses can call in and ask
questions and get support so um we'll
see what happens tomorrow